you're welcome to this video playing MLM
from the US and this is astonished of a
session and I did some warm-up games
yeah not some like - I think and I lost
them both badly so let's hope for some
improvement Jim in the Kings Indian No
and then you get some some boring guy
exchanging 25 yeah de 5 is the better
move I think but it's so boring maybe he
just takes anyway 94 could be the way to
try something yeah this is a very dull
okay
I mean I hit play the exchange sometimes
myself with h3 often
hmm
yeah but quite sure what this is about
Queeny for well anyway let's see what
happens I need to play c6 probably
anyway at some point trying to control
squares Bishop f8 one possible idea
yeah I guess this position should be
about equal he can try that but okay
it's exchanging his bad bishop the
LightSquared bishop but this is not
enough to to really play for our fun
advantage night f-4e 6d form is one idea
for black it's about equal disposition
yeah white is slightly slightly more
comfortable but it's nothing nothing
serious
at least I don't don't think so okay so
should I yeah okay the question is now
should i Fred take or should I ignore
this he might play b6 look a seven
something like that check came I don't
really want to go seven
the night has ideas to go to deform but
also this bishop f8 attacking this c5
thorn
yeah I think if white wants to pretend
for anything he needs to play b6 and
maybe there is something after b6 for
white it's not completely out of the
question
he kept maybe attack v7 the good thing
for me is I played rather quickly for
once yes this is this is also an idea
it's not really something I do believe
in this particular position but it's an
idea simply because my knight on d4 I
think this is too much really
the knight is is a good good piece I
just threatened night b5 now
yeah okay let's let's play quickly for
once not get into big-time trouble this
breaks up the pawns I must make sure
that this isn't a sound formation
anymore v6 Queen d6 is easy it takes
Queen d6 is also I think quite quite
easy to play yeah I don't I don't need
to take this is this is the point wait
wait wait wait just for just for a
moment think about this one precise move
might might help the bishop is clearly
good here to protect the b8 square
there's more than one move winning the
game probably but playing precisely as
some may be helping to make it easy
a 95 was just too much
it's a vetted idea to play the Sun night
move play together side yes that's just
no play the specialist is always this
Bishop is always controlling the vital
BH square we can go back to 95 because
in general this is an idea I mean to get
those three pawns going but in this
particular position it simply doesn't
doesn't work I think why should probably
play b6 him b6
Queen p.m. but he must he must be
careful in a way I have quite quite a
number of pieces attacking the spawn so
it was also 94 of course a drupe d8 yeah
or maybe capture on c6 and I think it's
it's really not much happening here
black is completely solid I have this I
have this as a as a target but 95 was
just were just not working here because
of the active night if let's say
theoretically speaking of course I go 94
but let's say for once it would be 98
that I need to play over this is even a
concrete problem but let's say the night
would be passive then then it is very
very dangerous but I have deformed so
it's it's just this important detail
that the good night goes to d4 changes
the video evaluation completely alright
glad to have played a decent game after
the two terrible warmups thanks for
watching